patrick et sandrine rolland ont repris
le travail dans leurs entreprises de
travaux publics
mais depuis trois ans une part d'eux
mêmes restent bloqués en alsace le 14
novembre 2015 ils sont invités avec
leurs deux enfants dans la rame d'essai
de la ligne à grande vitesse paris
strasbourg mais dans une courbe en
survitesse le tgv terrail l'accident
fera 11 morts dont alain rolland le
frère de patrick expert voix sur le
projet c'est leur petit cartron les
projets confrères sa collègue et puis
des années qu'on connaît quoi voilà
souvenir que j'ai de lui pour nous la
vie de famille qu'on finit cette
histoire depuis une longue procédure
judiciaire est en cours
le dernier rapport d expertise pointue
la responsabilité de la sncf ainsi que
des incompétences de personnel de la
filiale chargée des essais mais pour
patrick rolland c'est négliger la
responsabilité des conducteurs de la ram
pour moi les personnes vraiment en cause
de l'accident c'est les personnes qui
étaient dans la dans la loco voilà les
trois personnes qui logiquement devait
emmener cette trame problèmes quels que
soient les implications personnelles
reste l'idée que l'occident aurait dû
être évité et qu'il est temps d'avoir
des réponses pour les victimes
on veut que ça évite maintenant très
très vite au niveau des expertises bon
je pense qu'ils ont pratiquement tout
croquer un jugement rapinât on essaye de
passer à autre chose
la famille espère des avancées dans
l'année aucune date n'a pour l'instant
été fixée pour le procès